you say kakuchi
making his tenth start on the year a two
and three record era just over four he's
really pitched well as last five games
56 innings 19 walks but 56 strikeouts
for him
here's the pitch on the way and a swing
and a miss by garcia for strike three
and that's going to retire the side
and you say kikuchi with his first
strike
john young turns towards center field
and holds his cap
against his heart
before climbing up onto the mound and
standing on the rubber
the wind up and the 2-2 pitch on the way
to lewis swinging a line shot base hit
over the head of the shortstop kinder
philippa
and into left center field lewis waiting
on that pitch hit it hard
into the gap
now the mariners have runners on at
first and second with two outs bottom of
any number one and that'll bring up
first baseman ty france
hammered
hooking and gets by the left over
calhoun lewis scores easily seeger will
get the stop sign
and ty france checks in with an rbi
double
boy he abused it
put him away quickly
two strikeouts two out second inning
drives this into the game
bacon motor
all the way to the fence
gallow tracks it down
and donovan walton will shut it down
right there his first double of the
season he's got a triple
still looking for his first home run
it's a two-out double
[Applause]
and ty france coming up prince has a
chance to hang a crooked number
here in this third inning lewis at third
seeger at second
up the middle base hit louis scores
seger getting the wavelength he'll score
easily tied france having a day
driven in all three runs for the
mariners who lead three nothing here in
the third
right at kyle lewis
[Applause]
one away here in the fourth
that is
a strikeout
of nick solak the third of the afternoon
for kikuchi
32 to garcia
ground ball to gp
oh
he threw it away
[Applause]
should have been 12 up 12 down
to record the out
and you say kikuchi looking good through
four
there's a broken bat pop-up somewhere in
the left field
and it's willie calhoun
crossing the line into foul ground there
where the seating ball juts out closest
to the foul line and he makes the catch
oh two to low
three call
fourth strikeout for kikuchi two away in
the fifth here's co2
popped it up how about 99.
that'll get it done mayfield
there you go one two three in the fifth
no hitter looks through five three
nothing mariners
here seeger kyle is walked he's singled
and he scored 3-2 to seeger
high drive right field going back gallow
going back and he
did not get it home run kyle seeger
joey gallo big guy to bet 6'4 looked
like he might have got a glove on it
could pull it back in sega with a home
run
that's his tenth of the season the
mariners have a four-nothing lead over
the texas rangers
coochie gonna face eight nine in one
here in the sixth inning retired the
first 11 men that he faced looked like
it was going to be 12 and a throw got
away from j.p crawford
and there's a first base head
it's off the battle willie calhoun
defense give coochie a nice round of
applause for
going five innings of no hit ball the
one-two
swinging a ground ball punched in the
grass third base side seeger has it
throws across his body onto second for
one on to first it is in time
mayfield with the turn onto first base
what a play seeger to mayfield to france
and it wipes away the only hit of the
day for the rangers now the one-two
swing and a miss a helpless wave at 97
mile an hour cheese up and away connor
felefa back to the dugout so is kikuchi
six brilliant innings
now joey is grounded out twice today
this ball pounded deep out to center
field that one's carrying well gone
a two-run homer for joey gallo
the rangers are on the board
and it's a 4-2 ball game rangers back to
within two
not a bad pitch it was a cutter it was
down
ground ball jp backhand off balance
throw
and a tag applied
by
ty france two down
kikuchi goes six and two thirds mostly
brilliant baseball today good run
support from ty france and kyle seeger
and he'll leave to a big round of
applause if he's building as we speak
well deserved
[Music]
two one pitch
this will be two
we go to the ninth
baroners three outs away from
another sweep of the rangers it's 4-2
seattle
[Music]
infield and outfield playing davis
straight up 0-1 pitch here from
middleton
line drive right field kellnick's there
and the meredith's win this ball game
four to two they sweep the rangers and
the members are back to
527 and 27 it's the 12th consecutive
loss at t-mobile park by the rangers